I know that you had said that you are a
Harbury and a fan yeah but as we move
forward into part two team Harvey or
team Nick oh man I mean it's interesting
because I think that Sabrina and Nick
are so perfect for each other in the
second season especially because I think
Harvey is as much as I love him and I
adore him he's scared of Sabrina in a
lot of ways he's terrified of her power
and Nick isn't I can choose to be afraid
of my powers or I can use them he
admires her power and he champions
Sabrina and he lifts her up in a way
that I think is just a really wonderful
thing for people and young viewers to to
see in the general sense they are sort
of a dynamic duo in a lot of ways
and whereas Sabrina and Harvey's
relationship was truly like based in
love and sweetness and kindness Nick and
Sabrina's relationship is more based off
of kind of a partnership yeah their
partners in crime in a lot of ways so I
love it - this is uncharted territory
Harvey for sure I think he'll that was
is often pushing Sabrina to their mortal
side she doesn't trust Nick and you will
see later on why cuz I kept saying early
on I kept saying to Gavin who plays Nick
I was like why does she know my cute
something is different about somebody no
next lovey like he really genuinely
seems like a good guy but you know he'll
does not roll Harvey's for the endgame I
think I mean yeah yeah I was right
I love Gavin as a person so like I'm
really starting to lean on team Nick
well that's the thing - if the viewer
tends to swing with the lead yeah with
Kiernan so if she's falling in love with
Nick the audience probably little - so I
have a feeling of maybe along those
lines but I do love the Harvey and
Sabrina relationship I love how sweet it
is I love you Sabrina so I think that
Tati is team Harvey
simply because like you gotta love a
sweetheart like he's so sweet and so
like he will do anything for Sabrina I
mean so Nick to a certain extent but
it's just like he keeps the good alive
in her and I like that I think it's
precious but I think prudence is team
dick just cuz you know everyone else who
loves a bad boy it's nice that prudence
would give her seal of approval cuz you
know Nick and prudence had a bit of a
thing right
right so you know it's been a long time
coming you know Prince is finally like
I've gotta let it go I've got new things
on there Rises you had me at boys to
torment
are you team Harvey or team Nick ham
Bruce Harvey and Ambrose let the
fanfiction begin
I expect memes I'm sure it's already
Alex Sarah
Ambrose is team Harvey chances team Nick
now
Ambrose's team Harvey because Harvey is
wholesome javi is good for Sabrina and I
pied it around with Nick
well Ambrose is pied around with Nick
he's he's kind of been involved with the
witchy side so he might think that Nick
might be a bit bad news a charming young
man but don't touch my cousin it's not
even funny
Ambrose oh come on cuz it is a little
funny I stay up late at night thinking
about this constantly I've lost several
hours of sleep over it obviously because
I love my character but I also love
Harvey and Sabrina's chemistry and
they're like the og lovers you know what
I mean like they're they have such a
history and it's pure and innocent while
with Nick it's a bit more passionate and
it's just different
and as a viewer I'm split but I'm like
60/40 70/30 team Harvey okay yeah I
trade all the witch orgies in the world
from you an immortal have had I
because of what happened I'm team I want
Harvey and Nick to get together because
sotas raw Ross and Gavin really love
each other a lot and would love to see
some now reaction mm-hmm which is
probably not gonna happen but it's fun
to think about sorry mr. reader do you
think miss Wardwell is team Harvey or
team Nick I think she's team team Satan
really to be honest and she's a really
care who she's with as long as she's
right with the picture
hey team Satan and I love it she had a
dark baptism and there's nothing we can
do to stop her
[Music]